Oh No hey this is everyday I'm de
Christmas threw up on our set and I'm
covered in dog hair you know what that
means
South Park preview
what the Steven staven it's a miracle I
don't understand a whole new bicycle
dead you're the greatest
you must have gotten our Prime
membership back I guess I did the
bigwigs promoted me to manager
I've been training new employees we did
all this stuff arrived he just came a
few hours ago
Oh Steven you did it butters is so much
better for the bike parade now you
should see all the things he got squeaky
scared it's a boy folks if you watched
last week you know Jeff Bezos might be
an alien I'm not sure but Amazon
everyone's afraid of it and everyone
works in the town at Amazon it was that
a sentence so what is that yeah you know
I feel good about it there's like the
smelly pine cones I think I'm allergic
to it yeah they're like oh yeah I want a
hold on what did you write I bought
stuff this weekend
I got blind about something yesterday
what'd you get I got 2019 wall calendar
so I can do the Jerry Seinfeld thing of
like I write every day I cross off that
day so I'm excited to have just a blank
calendar by the end of 2012 you're gonna
drown in systems yeah I saw you reading
a creativity vote today tweet an
Instagram and then I see you taking naps
on the couch literally every day well
yeah that's part of it yeah I just worry
there's too much sleeping yeah there's
just so much time spent like getting
ready to be productive and so many
systems in place to produce something
yep it is a problem and I'm buying a new
system to solve that problem I'm very
excited about what we just got on Amazon
we so we bought my dog a chew toy okay
but it is a chew toy where he destroys
it and it admits a sound of a dying
animal which humans can't hear but he
can register because all he wants to do
is burn
yeah oh my god give him that but I feel
like I don't want to be a part of it
yeah to do it and that's why I went to
real animal he's coming for your neck oh
he's killed a real squirrel before wolf
yeah oh what a murder squirrels he's
trained to kill mm-hmm he's a lethal
weapon I think I think Jeff Bezos you
know he is a drug lord and I think he's
something that is all that money yeah I
think he just likes books or he actually
is an alien like South Park thinks which
South Park has a long history with
aliens so let's check out one of the
clips right good company man good
morning miss Crabtree what I like
damnit he's still there
don't worry about him no dude if
something happens to him my parents are
gonna blame me yeah whatever you fat
bitch watch a jig side I said I have a
bad itch miss Crabtree you have to stop
[Music]
[Applause]
Cartman are those the same visitors you
saw shut up you guys it's not working we
have to do something well we can't do
anything for now that fat bitch won't
let us watch I said that rabbits eat
lettuce oh well yes I certainly do what
am I gonna do my little brothers been
abducted by aliens you farted bacon
brownies
you've probably seen an alien
I can't I don't know how to take that is
that a comedy than a dig tell me where
that's coming from
that's like experiences Wow okay thank
you no I have not seen a UFO there yeah
I saw one and it's just like this jump
you know I woke up in the middle of the
night and it's like that is a dream I
think aliens too except I mean for sure
they don't like there's no doubt but
like we wouldn't have seen them like
they don't care about us why would they
care about why just assume that they're
just as dumb as we are okay just
somewhere else you know what I mean yeah
what do you think in the crop circle
situation maybe the crop circles are all
just part of like a big reality show
which South Park thought of already
that's it baby you get my jag on hot
let's party yes suck my jag on yeah now
you suck on my jag on oh yeah stick your
finger in my frescia
oh yeah suck it suck that jag on dude I
have no idea what we're saying right now
but I have a feeling it's really really
wrong
Oh God my head what did we do
oh man I can't believe I sucked your
jaggon oh god we did suck each other's
yeah guns you kids won't tell anybody
about this right yeah no wait we won't
tell anybody if you don't cancel our
show oh I knew that was coming
they really got us by the nose wins the
show can still be good just to raise
everyone's memory so we don't know we're
a show
I'm sure you'll see that if you give our
world time it will become even more
outrageous and violent there's even
World War III to look forward to and
then we'll have to show anybody the
picture Kenny has it you guys sucking
each other's jag ons
all right all right are things you win
blackmail do you think it's possible
that the earth is a reality show I think
it's a great theory
honestly like yeah cuz I feel like the
older the older I get and like the more
people I mean I'm like wow everyone is
so sad and like so has so many problems
that it would be very interesting mm-hmm
one giant big brother I think it's more
I I'm like done something like very
scary deep dives on like what this
reality that we live in could be our
society will soon end because we as
humans are ending because robots will
soon like what we are as human beings
now is gonna be over very soon
wow what a hilarious show this and so
you robot don't find that funny it's all
I'm thinking we can do whatever we want
that's true we kind of already are so
they want to know astrology astrology
they're like funny if we did it that'd
be crazy
what if we just like made out on the
couch and it's like what the viewers are
asking for commenting right now they're
like you should do it guys this is like
check-offs gun you got to do it
perhaps after this clip we're about to
be welcomed into the universal society
all thanks to a father and son who broke
the warp barrier using only the parts in
this pinewood derby car Kent mr. Marsh
you were on with all the world leaders
hello
Godspeed mr. Marsh the National Francis
with you keudboon Rock with Hayley and
mr. Marsh
creates a horrify much hangout okay oh
I'd stand by huh I think it's I think
it's landing
our first encounter with
extraterrestrial life is about to happen
will it be like in Star Trek first
contact or will it be more like contact
with Jodie Foster
[Music]
I seek the life forms that made this
that's ours mr. alien we are the marshes
Randy and Stan oh yeah
you're gonna build me another onesie Oh
first contact just like when you two
kiss anyway anybody ever been in the Boy
Scouts Girl Scouts I wasn't the Girl
Scout there you go happens yeah and I
was asked to leave for being too
insensitive from the Girl Scouts what
troop I didn't like my attitude one time
in this girl okay we are like 12 years
old this girl by God Jim pecans - a
trail mix okay ooh
that's disgusting why would you do that
and I was you know okay well this is
certainly the streets episode I think
we've ever done and let's just go
straight to the shoutout very good so
this is from our Friday episode Steve
Rogers writes would love to see Macaulay
Culkin in a new home alone film that
picked up 20-plus years later and this
time it's his wife playing tricks on him
parentheses just cuz she wants to like a
good idea also that show is Thursday
whatever
thank you Steve Rogers for your comment
yeah Thank You Captain America oh thanks
thanks dude
that was so cool wha Marvin that's weird
about Captain Marvel
thanks for watching
[Music]